Veamos si podemos simplificar 6 a la 1/2 multiplicado por la raíz quinta de 6 elevado a la tercera potencia.
¿Ok? Ponle pausa al vídeo si quieres...
y bueno, puedes intentarlo pero...
¿Ok? Le voy a poner color a estos exponentes
para seguirles el rastro.
Y aquí tenemos el 1/2 en azul,
la raíz quinta en rosa
y en verde la tercera potencia.
Muy bien, ok, entonces, una manera de hacer esto
es primero pensar en esta raíz quinta,
esto... esto es lo mismo que elevar este 6
a la potencia 1/5,
creo que es un poco más cómodo entonces,
pongámoslo de esa forma,
6 a la 1/5
y esto elevado a la tercera potencia,
entonces, todo esto elevado a la tercera potencia...
¡Ah! y claro, también vamos a multiplicar por este 6
a la 1/2 no, no lo vamos a olvidar,
entonces por 6 a la 1/2
y así queda la multiplicación.
Ahora, ¿qué pasa si elevamos algo a un exponente
y a eso lo elevamos a otro exponente?
¿Qué pasa? ¿Qué, qué sucede?
Ya conocemos las propiedades de los exponentes
y entonces sabemos que esto es equivalente a elevar esto, al producto de estos dos exponentes,
así que esto es equivalente a 6...
a 6 a la 3 por 1/5 es igual a 3/5,
entonces 6 a la 3/5...
estoy usando los colores...
colores correctos entonces...
esto ya multiplicado por 6 a la 1/2...
por 6 a la 1/2...
6 a la 1/2 multiplicado por 6 a la 3/5
y si estás multiplicando esta base a este exponente y la misma base a otro exponente, de hecho todos estos...
todos estos son iguales, entonces,
voy a poner aquí que son iguales,
así que ok, esto, esto es igual a 6,
a 6 elevado
a la 1/2 más 3/5
por que tienen la misma base,
simplemente sumamos los exponentes y ya.
Así que sumemos, ok,
1/2 más 3/5, encontramos el denominador común,
el cual será 10 en este caso...
el denominador común será 10,
así que esto es igual a 6,
elevado
a 5 sobre 10 más 6 sobre 10...
5 sobre 10 más 6 sobre 10..
y ahora sumamos estas 2 fracciones,
esto es igual a 6...
a 6 elevado a la potencia
11 sobre 10...
6 a la potencia 11 sobre 10...
y como puedes ver parecía un monstruo al principio, pero no era, era, era solo un gatito,
¿Cierto?
No era tan difícil... bueno, nos vemos.